tiens on a trouvé beaucoup combien tu en
as trouvé
chaque année cette fête fait le bonheur
des amoureux du chocolat à pâques ses
traditions ses coutumes
la télé en parle depuis les années 50
l'un des symboles de cette fête
religieuse c'est l'oeuf qui représente
la renaissance
il est meilleur en chocolat adrien
vivian meilleur ouvrier de france et
pâtissiers confiseurs marseillais nous
démontre que la fabrication d'un oeuf de
pâques est une opération qu'un enfant
mènerez à bien
après neuf autres traditions pascales
les crécelles
attention à vos oreilles cet instrument
de musique fait du bruit beaucoup de
bruit
il est utilisé par les enfants de coeur
pour appeler les fidèles à la messe
direction un petit village en moselle
c'était en 1976 et ya longtemps que
cette tradition existe on veut bien
avant peut-être même c'est une tradition
et vous continuez à vendredi
aujourd'hui cette tradition des crestel
existe toujours dans certaines régions
françaises
tout comme le fion oui le fion vous avez
bien entendu au poiré sur vie en vendée
ce gâteau traditionnel et préparé pour
célébrer la fête de pâques
la recette on vous la dent archives une
pâte pétrie vous allez voir
soigneusement plonger dans l'eau
bouillante puis qui sèche pendant
plusieurs jours il ne reste plus alors
qu'à verser le lait et crème et à faire
cuire le tout voilà le fion qui
paraît-il se déguste seul autre coutume
qui perdure les sharks fleuri dans le
sud de la france
chaque année les gens se déguiser
parcourent les rues de leur commune
comme ici en 2002 dans ce village de
dordogne où les habitants ne déroge pas
à la règle
ce parce que c'était le but
au départ de fabriquer des chars
travailler en équipe et mettre une
ambiance du moins dans le village
pendant deux à trois jours cette année
malgré la crise du coït 19 pas que sera
bien au rendez vous que les enfants se
rassurent ils pourront participer à la
traditionnelle chasse aux oeufs mais en
petit comité
[Musique]